[Musique]
bonjour dominique rey le via bonjour ont
suivi elle tend bien jour bonjour j'ai
dit aux auditeurs vous êtes chargé
d'enseignement à l'université également
consultante en silver economy cette
économie dédié aux seniors
nous sommes en pleine semaine bleue
dominique revient avec comme thème à
tout âge faire société c'est bien joli
slogan
sauf que pour faire société on va dire
qu'il faut avoir la tête à cela
quelle est la situation générale de nos
retraités la situation de nos seniors en
martinique alors en martinique il est à
peu près 60 de mille retraités 1 2 du
régime général ce sont aussi c'est une
pension moyenne à peu près de 646 euros
et c'est aussi 27% en fait ces personnes
qui touchent l'allocation de solidarité
c'est à dire le minimum vieillesse
contre 3,1 pour cent ans dans l'hexagone
646 euros 646 euros
oui tout à fait mais c'est doit-on en
pleurer je pense parce que en fait le
seuil de pauvreté c'est à peu près 1000
euros par mois donc 646 euros ce n'est
pas beaucoup pour vivre et cela fait des
années que l'on dit que la martinique
risque d'être un département comptant le
plus de seniors dans dents sur le
territoire français comment peut-on
comment droite on concevoir des
politiques lorsqu'on sait qu'on va
s'adresser à des gens qui en moyenne on
dit bien en moyenne touche une telle
somme alors ça veut dire qu'il faut
absolument les aider les accompagner
parce qu'en fait c'est vrai qu'on parle
beaucoup des personnes qui sont en
situation de dépendance bon c'est vrai
que c'est un phénomène de plus en plus
important mais il ya aussi énormément de
seniors actifs qu'ils soient souffrent
d'isolement social soit souffrent de
maladies et toutes ces personnes là en
fait si on ne s'occupe pas d'elle en
fait vont entrer en dépendance d'ici
quelques années donc c'est pourquoi il y
a quand même enfin un petit peu un rayon
de soleil un je dirais dans dans cet
horizon là il y a quand même un certain
nombre d'organismes dont la cij ss de la
martinique la sécurité sociale oui
pardon de la martinique
bientôt la conférence des financeurs qui
met en place et subventionne des
ateliers de prévention en direction des
seniors alors dos les cadavres de
poursuivre cet entretien est ce que tu
es que le port on n'a pas cherché à
noyer le poisson avec ce terme générique
de seniors on est senior à partir de
quel âge finalement alors tout dépend je
dirais de la vision de l'angle sur
lequel on se place
bon alors quand on est dans le domaine
médical c'est plutôt appartient de 70
ans
on parle quand on commence à avoir des
maladies véritable dans le monde de
l'entreprise c'est vrai que ce à partir
de 45 parfois 45 ans qu'on est considéré
comme senior de déco séquençage de noyer
le poisson
c'est vraiment rechercher de nouvelles
niches économiques et en et seniors à
partir de 45 ans parce que son pouvoir
d'achat
ça veut partir par exemple d'été et des
loisirs oui c'est vrai effectivement
mais il faut savoir nos seniors comme on
disait tout à l'heure n'ont pas
forcément comment dire les moyens à
l'heure de jeu voir partir alors
justement faire société faire société
pour cela il faut des moyens matériels
intellectuels et financiers on l'a dit
oui comment faire alors comment faire
alors tout à l'heure on en parlait donc
on parlait de ces fameux ateliers qui
sont mis en place
il ya aussi les ccs qui en font un
travail je dirais de fond les
associations il y est je dirais les
seniors à sortir de l' isolement
il ya aussi de sa mise en jeu c'est ça
le plus probable isolement oui les
allemands sociale il faut savoir de plus
en plus les petits enfants ou les
enfants n'habitent pas
sur place puisque justement si on dit
c'est qu'on a un problème au niveau de
notre jeunesse
donc les seniors sont de plus en plus
seul et je mets en avant sept
comment dire cette initiative de la
ville de schoelcher qui s'appelle allô
bonjour qui consiste en fait tous les
matins à appeler les seniors pour savoir
s'ils vont billétique de schoelcher de
de prendre soin d'eux et des seigneurs
et des autres équipes les seniors en
les seniors de martinique qui redoutent
surtout ces annonces du gouvernement
d'augmenter la contribution sociale
généralisée sans contrepartie est-ce que
comment comment ils le perçoivent cela
vous en discuter avec eux alors non
c'est vrai que localement on n'a pas eu
on n'a pas connu je dirais les
mouvements sociaux qu'il y a eu sur sur
dans l'hexagone
bon comme on disait tout à l'heure nous
retraités sont moins
comment dire moins d'argent de son pote
qui seront peut-être moins touchés par
ce problème là mais c'est vrai que pour
les retraités je dirais qu'il touche au
dessus de 1200 euros
ça va faire comme une vraie coupes dans
leur budget sans contrepartie on le
rappelle sans contrepartie alors il ya
plusieurs solutions là c'est vrai que
nous sommes pas maîtres de ces solutions
là au niveau national une des solutions
ça serait par exemple de supprimer la
cotisation maladie qui est prélevée sur
leurs retraites complémentaires comme
les actifs comme ça va se faire pour les
actifs
ça serait aussi par exemple à de déduire
de leur revenu imposable pour ceux qui
sont imposés bien sûr une cotisation les
cotisations de mutuelle parce qu'on sait
que les mutuelles seniors c'est quelque
chose qui est très important et au
niveau maladie etc
au niveau local une des solutions ça
pourrait être parce qu'on sait qu'un
problème de transport
ça pourrait être par exemple enfin si je
n'ai pas prévu de créer une carte senior
généralisé alors je ne parle pas
seulement du tcsp je ne parle pas
seulement des bus sur la cacem mais
aussi dans toute la martinique ça peut
être le transport en commun pourrait
avoir une réduction
bon maintenant il ya d'autres solutions
je dirais pour créer le lien social
aussi bas c'est de plus en plus
organiser le covoiturage je vais faire
des courses et bien j'emmène ma voisine
et je peux faire enfin on peut faire ça
mais c'est vrai mais en fait l'idée ce
serait de faire quelque chose d'organisé
enfin ça peut être par exemple un ccs ou
une association qui propose voilà tel
jour on va en covoiturage tel endroit
pour aller faire des courses pour aller
au cinéma et c'est vraiment résoudre le
problème de du transport en dehors du
transport il ya aussi le problème de
logement
certains seniors en de grands logements
donc pourquoi ne pas développer le lasso
vieux location au sol à l'aide de ces
quartiers on a vu par exemple des des
salariés dans les années 70-80
construire de grandes maisons parce que
en france et c'est maintenant ses
enfants sont partis et ses retraités se
retrouve tout seul chez eux avec parfois
des conjoints qui sont partis on se
retrouve tout seul et il y avait eu des
tentatives par exemple que ces personnes
âgées accueillent des étudiants ce qu'il
faut absolument développer
moi je pense alors pas seulement les
étudiants ça peut être aussi des
familles de plus en plus dans l'hexagone
c'est une forme je dirais de colocation
qui se développe dans un même logement
on a on héberge une famille qu'elle soit
monoparentales ou pas donc ça peut
résoudre le problème du lien social et
de l'isolément
donc ça c'est une solution jacrot de
creton monde main et parlé des progrès
si c'est vrai alors est-ce qu'on fait
qu'est ce qu'on fait il ya du travail à
faire sur les sur les mentalités
oui mais oui je pense qu'il ya un
travail à faire à ce niveau là et puis
c'est vrai que enfin pour certaines
personnes âgées en sont seraient prêtes
peut-être prêt tard à sauter le pas ils
vous parlent également dominique celvia
lorsqu'on a préparé cet entretien de cet
isolement qui peut ce qui peut
s'accentuer également à cause de la
fracture numérique
oui c'est un mauvais au moment où les
institutions demandent de plus en plus
que tout soit fait en ligne sur une
déclaration à la caisse générale de
sécurité sociale même la déclaration
d'impôt qui manie regrets parce que les
seniors 65 ans qui qui qui qui qui
jouent avec leur tablette qui
connaissent parfaitement les choses il
ya aussi des seigneurs de 90 ans
alors à mon avis la seule solution c'est
ce sont des ateliers d'accompagnement je
sais que la caisse de sécurité sociale
propose pendant cette semaine bleue des
ateliers pour apprendre à utiliser
amélie 1
leaké le site en fait pour pouvoir voir
cela fait effectivement je sais que la
caisse d'allocations familiales avait
pour projet de mettre en place ce type
d'atelier non là vraiment en fait c'est
vraiment l'accompagnement nous nous
proposons des ateliers pour pouvoir
faire des démarches administratives en
ligne
bon je pense que dans quelques années on
n'aura plus ce souci de fractures enfin
en tout cas il sera moins important mais
aujourd'hui il faut traiter ce problème
et puis également l'aspect santé il
faudrait que nos seniors bouge un peu
plus mais je reviens sur cette pension
moyenne 642 euros lorsqu'on voit la
paire le prix d'une paire de chaussures
dans un magasin de sport à fort de
france ça coûte déjà 150 200 euros pour
une bonne paire de chaussures
surtout avec des pieds un peu
fragilisées de monseigneur à quel moment
peut-on faire du sport à cet âge là
alors via cévennes moyens alors ils y
allaient ccs qui organise un certain
nombre d'ateliers donc vraiment les
seniors il faut qu'ils se rapprochent
soin de leurs ccs soit des associations
de quartier parce qu'il ya quand même
des solutions ou soit à travers ces
programmes-là dont nous avons parlé
le programme bien vieillir il y a des
choses qui se font
bon maintenant ce n'est pas le sport
mais il ya aussi une université du temps
libre
enfin y existe quand même un certain
nombre de choses globalement mais j'ai
quand même l'impression que la situation
de nos seniors est de plus en plus
prises en compte
louise riches at ans oui je pense afin
de nous ça fait plus de cinq ans que
nous sommes dans la silver economy
et c'est vrai que aujourd'hui on
s'aperçoit qu'il ya de plus en plus de
programmes en direction des seniors
il faut vraiment qu'ils se renseignent
et qu'il s'informe dernière question des
primes très rapidement dominique furne
via la silver economy on y va pour se
faire du fric
ouais au faux pas du tout pas papa en
martinique dans la mesure où dans les
antilles dans la mesure où on a vu qu'il
y a un pouvoir d'achat qui est peu
important merci d'avoir été se battre
avec nous deux brits créateurs rappelle
que vous êtes consultant silver economy
et que vous avez cette société qui
s'appelle apic silver merci bonne
journée
merci
[Musique]
d